inflation really is the problem that
won't quite go away and you can see how
sticky it is here the blue line where
over the hump but it's not falling
anywhere near as fast as policy makers
would like it stayed flat at 8.7 last
month that's considerably higher than
the bank's two percent Target and look
at this before the lockdown it's also a
lot higher than the type of inflation
we're used to in the UK so we've got
some way to go to get it back down and
when we're thinking about what's driving
this persistent inflation well you can
see that food and drink is easing off
right the bottom there that red line but
prices here are still rising at an
annual rate of 18 so don't be fooled by
that red bar meanwhile at the top in the
blue it's Leisure Pursuits like eating
out Recreation and culture that are now
driving inflation
so even though prices are rising people
are still finding money to spend and
it's possibly why the bank of England is
worried about robust pay Rises that
workers in Britain have been securing
and this type of spending is becoming
increasingly a problem we will often
hear that inflation is a global problem
caused in part by factors out of our
control like the energy crisis but if we
strip away volatile items like food and
energy out of the headline rate we can
see that underlying pressures so that's
the red line or core inflation in the UK
is rising
that's something our counterparts in
Europe and the US are not grappling with
and all of this it's uncomfortable for a
government that's trying to figure out
how it may tempt voters next year ahead
of a general election government debt as
you can see here is a proportion of GDP
is at its highest since the 1960s and
soaring interest rates makes servicing
that debt all the more painful
so it's a tough State of Affairs for a
country grappling with the cost of
living crisis and a government that's
been talking tough on inflation but not
yet delivering the desired results